では よろしくお願いします
七十六番から  今日は本当に悪い天気の中で申し訳ないんですけど
私なら部屋に閉じこもって寝たい気分なんですけど
今日は七十六番ね 六章にパンディトワッガ
パンディトワッガというのは賢者って誰ですかという
まあ一応賢者とパンディタという言葉がある偈をまとめただけで
別にこれだけで賢者の理性人の説明尽くすというわけじゃないんです
まあいろんなところにありますし
たまたまその単語が入っているだけをまとめていることでね
ニ
ディーナンウェパワッタランヤンパスセワッジャダッシナニッガイヤワーディンメーダーウィンターディサンパンディタンバジェーターディサンバジェマナンサセイヨホーティナパピヨ
ニディーナンウェパワッタランヤンパスセワッジャダッシナニッガイヤワーディンメーダーウィンターディサンパンディタンバジェーターディサンバジェマナンサセイヨホーティナパピヨ
と まあ賢者は何なのかということではなくて
ニディーナンというのはこの隠してある宝物のことなんですね
その宝物のありか パワッタランというのは教えてくれる
ヤンパスセワッジャダッシナ
そのように誰かに 誰かが自分の間違いを見抜くならばね
ニッガイワワーディンというのは
まあニッガイヤっていうのは非難することで
怒鳴ることというかね
躾することとか まあ批判することですね
いつでもまあ批判する
そのようなメーダーウィン
智慧のある人 ターディサンパンディタンバジェー
そのような賢者と付き合ってくださいと
一番後ろから意味を取ってみてください
パンディタンバジェー
賢者と付き合いなさいと
賢者って誰ですかというと
ニッガイワーディン いつでももう怒鳴ってるだけで悪口言ってるだけっていう
全然褒めてくれないんですね
あれも悪い これも悪い
これは間違ってるとか
そういう悪いところばっかり言ってるんだと
メーダーウィンというのは本当はものすごい頭がいい
智慧があるんです 智慧があるんだけど
もう何か口を開けたらもう相手の間違いを言ってるばっかりで
だからヤンパスセワッジャダッシナ
ワッジャっていうのは過ち
間違いですね もうただ単にいたずら怒鳴ってるわけじゃなくて
ワッジャ 間違いをすぐ見抜いて
これが間違い これが間違いと
まあ言うんですね そのように自分の人生において間違いをしっかりと教えてくれることは
隠れている 隠している大変な大事な宝物のありかを教えてくれることと同じだと
この宝物の話っていうのはね
よくあることでね 西洋の物語でもね
子供たちの物語ではね
いろいろ宝物探しに何か古い地図を持って
いろいろ暗号を解読しながら行くという話っていうのはいくらでもあります
で インドでもいわゆるパーリ仏典でも
やっぱり昔人々はたくさん金財産
金銀宝石あった場合は
これがどこかで隠しておくと
決して自分の家で隠しておくわけにはいきませんね
すぐ見つかりますからね
だからどこかに隠しておく
これは決してバレないようにする
で 宝物をバレないようにしたっても
やっぱり自分が亡くなったらね
自分の子供たちがそれ使ってほしいし
だからといって子供たちに簡単に教えちゃうとね
それはもう森の中ですから
行って持って行ってね
なんかしてしまっちゃうとね
これまた困るし だからいろいろ暗号やらいろんな方法で
その宝物のありかを歌に作っておいたりとか
それが子供たちに教えてあげたりはする
で 皆様はね スイス銀行の口座を覚えているような感じで
なんとか歌にしてね 覚えておけば
どうやって覚えてますかね
スイス銀行の口座は あれ番号すごく長いんですけど
まあ私は持ってないんだからわかりません
だから番号さえ言えば
スイス銀行の場合は身分証明書か何も要りません
番号だけ そのニダーナっていうのは
そういう風に宝物を隠しているところ
で 宝物を隠して隠す 隠しているところのありかを教えてくれるような言葉であると
自分の間違いを教えてくれる言葉ね
ですから その人が頭の悪くて
ただ口が悪いだけだったらどうったことはないんですけど
知恵のある人はね よく叱るんですよ
だからいくら叱られても
いくら怒鳴られても 知恵のある人についていくんです
その人の話を聞くんです
で しょっちゅうあれもこれは違うでしょう
これは違うでしょうと
いつでも言われますけど
最後ターディサンバジャマーナナ
そのような人と付き合っていると
セイヨーホーティ日々優れた人間になるんだと
パーピヨ 決して あの 悪い人間にはなりませんと
より悪しき人になるのではなく
より良い人になるんだよという意味なんですね
そういうことで この一つは智慧のある
本当に優しい頭の良い人の性格も説明しながら
まあ頭が良いつもりでいる人々はどうするべきかということも説明しているところなんですね
良いつもりでいたっても
あまり役に立たない すぐバレるし
ですから とにかく智慧のある人と仲良くしてみてくださいと
しかし 智慧のある人と仲良くするということはそう簡単でもないんですね
結構叱られるんだからね
ことで注釈書ではね まあいい例えがありまして
とても貧困な人がいて
その人をね ぶん殴って
消して蹴って怒鳴って
でも財産をあげるならば
その人は決して嫌だと思わないんだよと
すごい貧乏な人がいて
その人にもものすごく怒鳴って
すごくもう殴ったりして
なんていい人ですかと
お前は これ持ってきなさいと
殴ったんだけど すごい大金
大金あげる その人はあの野郎に殴られたとか思いますかね
思わないです やっぱり私のことを心配しているんだと
私は怠け者で 人にものを乞うてせいで惨めな生活をしていることにはものすごく腹が立っているみたいだと
だからものすごい宝物
大金をくれたんだと ですから
これから二ともない惨めな生活してはいけませんと
なんという人ですかと思うんです
ですから この賢者に叱られることっていうのは
ありがたく思う人も その時点で智慧のある人なんですね
見込みのある人なんです
だから 誰が賢者ですか
誰が愚か者ですかという場合はね
知恵を育てている人は当然賢者であって
まあその育てる知恵の卵も賢者扱いするんです
先生 今は知恵のひとかけらもないんだけど
これから成長する種だけは持っている
その人も智慧のある人として見込むんですよ
ですから 智慧のたまげは賢者と付き合う
いくら賢者に怒鳴られても
けなされても 否定されても
全然そういうことは全く気にもしない
その代わりにこの人からいろんなことを学ぶでしょうと
この人いなくなったら私は誰から学ぶんでしょうかということで
そういう人と付き合うんですね
だから仏教では戦友というのもそのようなことで
で よくある疑問ですね
良いもの 良い友達って誰でしょうかとかね
悪友とは付き合うなよとはっきり言っているし
だからこの世の中で戦友いるのかどうかもよくよく私にも質問されたことがありますし
そこで問題は戦友がいても我々はその人と付き合うのかということなんです
私たちは大嫌いでしょうね
批判する人のこと とにかく自分を認めてほしいとね
自分を褒めてほしいと評価してほしいという
これ一点張りでしょ それで何の卵かと分かりますね
智慧がなくても智慧の卵なら
それでは終わらないんですね
叱る 怒鳴ることができないように
ものすごく嫌な失礼な雰囲気まで作ったりする
強引に言ったりもする
こうしなさい ああしなさいと
目上の人に命令するするのは大体日本だけですけどね
アドバイスまでする 管理まですようとする
あんたこういう風に歩きなさい
こういう風に喋りなさいとかね
まあそれとは仏教の世界は違うだけの話で
何も得られないだけ そう簡単じゃないんですね
性格を変えるということは
自分からのそういう性格だったら変わりません
あれ禅の物語だって ある禅寺がある人が一生懸命座禅組んでるんで
いつ見たっても座禅組んでいる
中国の話で禅師がそちらに行って邪魔をしてね
君 お前何やってるの？だって先生
私は座禅組んで座禅やってるの
あら なんで山だ？なぜ座禅やってる？私はブッダになりたいと
うん なるほどと言って
壊れたもう捨てた瓦の破片があったんです
そこら辺に だからその禅師が瓦のこの破れたその瓦を持ってきて
そこら辺そばに座って
結構音を立てながら一生懸命これを磨くんですね
うるさいんですね 座禅組んで座禅組んでるし
修行中の人にとっては
あまりもうるさいんだから
禅師何なさってるんでしょうか？と
あのね 私はこれを磨いて鏡にしてやろうと思ってるんだよと
言ったら いくらなんでも先生ね
この腐りかけてる壊れてる瓦がね
鏡にはなりませんよ あ
そう じゃあお前ブッダになるわけもないんだと言って禅師が帰って帰っていったと
だからまあ そこはやっぱり智慧のある人々の話で
その人はいかに頑固でわがままでいい加減なやつかと
その座禅組んでいる人がね
けしからんなやつらと言ってますよ
でも言えないんだから
真面目に座禅組んでいるんだから
こんな真面目に真剣に修行している私に対して
こんな無礼侮辱 禅師は何者かと逆になるでしょうに
そういうことで まあ見事に教えてあげたというかね
だからやっただけでね
なるということでもないんですよ
ものすごくややこしい
仏教は性格ね 変えること
性格の成長 人格向上することが仏教ですから
そこら辺ではすごい厳しいんです
ものすごくはっきり言うんです
出ていけという場合は出ていけとはっきり言うんです
もうただもう何のもう成長もする見込みがなく
見えだけで形だけであってね
まあもう逆に教える人々にとってはものすごく失礼な態度を取ったりするし
このすごい丁寧にやるという
あれ失礼なんですよ 本当は
だって心の中は違いますからね
どこか歩くどの前土下座したりしちゃうとね
あれってえらい失礼なんですけど
で 本人が騙したとは先生はよく騙せました
丁寧に挨拶してとかね
騙せませんね 賢者の賢者っていうのは礼をしてもしなくてももうわかってるんだからね
で 直せない人に対しては親切ですからね
また直れない見込みがない
それから親切です 余計なトラブルは作りたくない
もし知恵の珠だとわかったら
放っておかないんですね
善い事したっても怒鳴りつける可能性あります
そういうわけで 無理ということですね
結論として言えば 現代人には知恵のある人になるということはね
こういう世界ではやっぱり本当に無理ですよ
だからどこでも褒めなくちゃいけない
小学生までもう無茶苦茶褒めなくちゃいけない
会社でちょっと仕事できないんだから怒ったと怒鳴ったら会社辞めてくるんだからね
それで私は会社辞めて
なんで辞める？いえ これから瞑想すると思ってるんだと言ったとたん分かりますけど
私が 私から見たらえらい迷惑です
あなた方はと こんな言いたいんですよ
あなた方ちょこっとでも瞑想しているのは見たらね
もう見る見る人がもう全然瞑想しないことになりますよと
気持ち悪い 気持ち悪いと
なんであんな暗い連中だと思っちゃい
でもそこらへんなかなか言えないしね
だからこの ちょっと怒鳴っただけでね
私は辞めたとかね だったらこちらが来てはいけません
こちらはまあ時間の中で時間怒鳴れますからね
それは怒鳴らないと思います
倍怒鳴ればいいんだからね
まあだからまあ性格を直すところではかなり厳しく言われます
だから我々はそれが嫌だったらもう見込みがないんですよ
やっぱりもう嫌やと だからまあやっぱり小さい時にそこは教えてあげないと
人間は人格が向上しません
小さい時は褒めて褒めて育てるんだからね
怒鳴る 叱ることには慣れてないって習わせないんですね
わざと 親が 習えるようにしないんですね
それでどんな人間になりますかというと
戦争に参加できないことは大恥やという
なく人々がいる社会になるんです
これで日本は国際的に貢献できる国になるのかと
これは日本の歴史的に恥だと
イラク戦争にただで灯油
石油を配ることできなかったんだから
このお金で日本の中でもっと石油の値段でも下げてくれればいいんですけど
やっぱり善悪判断 物事を理解できる能力っていうことは全部なくなってしまいます
だからね まあやっぱり成長する過程っていうのは厳しいもんですよ
成長するということは
我々の性格を直すということで
自分が今この性格であるということは
自分にとってはこれは正しいということでもありますね
だからこれが正しいと思っているものが正しくないと言われると
かなり気薄くなるんですね
ですから この知恵のある人になるということは
もう結構厳しい道はそういうところで厳しいんです
別に別の意味で厳しいわけじゃないんです
すごい単純なところで怒鳴られるのは嫌ですか？と
それで話が収束と 批判されるのは嫌ですか？と
それははい さようならと
頭が悪いかいうか 僕はあまり聞かないんです
頭が悪い 例えば何人も世間的な立場で頭が悪い人を言うんであって
知恵のある人になるということは
すごい簡単に簡単ではなくて
それは誰にでも可能なんです
しかし なぜなれないのかというと
批判するのされるのは嫌という
叱る叱られるのは嫌だと
そういうことで この世間にしたってもダメな連中でしょう
会社でも叱られるんだとか
それをびくともしないで自分のことやる人々はどんどん成長していきますよ
侮辱されたって全然全くびくともしないで自分のことをやると
そうなってくると もうみるみるうちに成長していくんです
うん まあいくらなんでもすごい立派な知恵のある人についていることができれば
叱られたっても まあそれでもありがたく思うケースというのは日本でもないわけじゃないんですけどね
やっぱりそれより先にね
我々はすごい抜群の知恵のある人に仲良くすることができるっていうことはね
まあなかなかないことですから
性格的に我々はやっぱり自分の間違いを教えてくれるところで
すぐすぐそこを習うというね
ことがあった方が たとえ賢者がいなくても自分が成長してはいけます
ものすごい小さなエピソードがありまして
エピソードと言えばほとんど関係ないんですけども
まあこのエピソードっていうのは
大体いろんな芸人も意味を理解してもらいたく言っていることで
あるものすごい貧しい貧乏なバラモンがいて
もう生活できないんだと
この人はね この人を考えたのは
なんかお坊さんたちのお世話でもして
そこら辺で何か生活できるんじゃないかなと思って
お坊さんたち住んでいるところに行って
その場所の掃除とかやってるんですね
とにかくお坊さんたちは雑草を取ったりもしないんだから
出家だからちゃんと雑草を取って
綺麗に場所を綺麗にしてあげたり
一生懸命やってます 水を汲んであげたり
いろんなこと お坊さんたちもまあ一生懸命やってるんだから
自分たちが托鉢に行って
帰るときはこの人を即自分の残して帰ってくるんですね
ですから お坊さんたちの鉢にあるご飯食べて生活はしている
ずっと一緒にいるんですけど
誰もこの人を出家させようとは思わないんですね
誰か誰かちょっと自分にご飯もらったら
じゃあこれをあの人に持ってってもらおうということで持っていってあげるだけで
この人はどんどん出家したくなりまして
なかなか出家してくれるという話がないんだから
まあちょっと落ち込んでどんどん痩せていくんですね
ある日お釈迦様 様がね
人々のことをね 自分の神通で観察するときは
このバラモンも入りました
変な人がお坊さんたちのところにいるんだということはね
その人はすごく精神的に悩んでいて
どういうことかと 本人は本当に真剣
真面目に仏道を歩みたいと思っているんですね
正直な気持ちなんです
だからお坊さんたちから見れば
これ貧乏な人がね ご飯狙ってきたでしょうと
ご飯狙ってきた人は決して出家させないんです
それすごい大変なことになる
迷惑になりますから これで楽に食べていられるなと思ったら
それだけでも失格で だからお坊たちにわからないんですね
真面目からも この人はもう食べ物なくてね
住むところがなくて 飢えていた人だから
寺に来て住み込んだだけ
だからまあ出家してあげようとは思うことはできないんですね
しかし お釈迦様から見れば
その人はそういう目的で来たかもしれませんだけど
仏道を歩みたいという気持ちはもう随分素直な正直な気持ちなんです
それで能力あるのか調べたら
かなり能力もあると じゃあこれ何とかしなくちゃということで
お釈迦様は何人かとお坊たちと一緒に
このお坊さんたちが住んでいるところに今行きましたと
行ったらまあこのバラモンもいるんだから
お釈迦様はあえてこのバラモン人と話してみるんですね
あんたはどこにいるの？こちらの寺にいるんだ
ああ そう こちらの僧だったらね
この比丘たちがあなたのことを心配していますかねとかね
というと はいはい まあ結構心配してます
私にはちゃんとご飯だけはちゃんとみんな持ってくるんだと
村から ご飯だけですよ
結局だと 出家もしたいんですけど
そこまで話はいかないんだと
言うとお釈迦様がそうということで
比丘たちが集めて あなた方が誰かこの人からね
まあお世話になったことはないんですかと
まあずっとその人を助けているんですけど
この人に この人に助けられても助けてもらったことはないんですかと
言ったらすごいいますし
まあ乞食みたいな人でしょうに
それでサーリプッタ尊者がいきなりお釈迦さんに
はいはい ありますと 私は思い出しまったと
どういうことかと 昔一回托鉢に出た時は
この人はちょこっとご飯もらっていて
そこからちょっと一匙ぐらい私にくれたことがありますと
あの ちょっと一匙 お布施したことがありますよと
これでもこの人は 自分にはちょっとあった時はね
それから自分にも食べ物ないんだからね
もうお布施するっていうことはありえないし
お釈迦様があなたも助けてくれたことがあるんだから
この人の苦しみをなくしてあげる義務がないのと
とサーリプッタ尊者に聞くんです
だから一般のお坊さんたちのところで弟子入りできなかったんですよ
お釈迦様はわざと偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者の弟子にさせたがってるんですよ
だからサーリプッタ尊者がはいわかりましたと
じゃあ出家させますと
言って そのバラモン人がもうバラモン人に出家させて
まあホームレスでしょうね
一応 だからまあちょっと合わないしね
お釈迦様の周りにいる人たちっていうのは
もうかなり社会的にも立場がある人々の間で
サーリプッタ尊者 なおさら立派で
それでももう大胆に見えたでしょう
当時ではね ある尊者がそんなにも考えない
はいはい 出家させますと
言って出家させて で いきなり出家だから何もわからないでしょうに
これから勉強するものは
しきたりやらものすごくたくさんありますからよ
一緒に連れていくんですね
どこでも サーリプッタ尊者
あえてわかっていますから
これわざわざお釈迦様が来んだことだから
これ大変なことだと こんな軽く見てはいけない
サーリプッタ尊者だからわかっているんです
だからもうずっと自分が直々指導することにしたんです
でなきゃ大勢のお坊さんたちがいるんだから
そこら辺から学んでくださいとね
もう言うんですよ しかし
この人の場合はそれもなく直々そばに居ておいて
言ってもサーリプッタ尊者からその晩まで叱ると
いつでもこれは違います
あれは違いますとかね
なぜそういうふうにするのかと
すっともうそういうことで
しかし この人は 言うとおりに
ダメと言ったことをやらないで
こうしなさいということをしっかりやって
すぐの間内に大やらかになるんです
で 悟りに達するんです
悟りに達したら サーリプッタ尊者の仕事は責任終わりましたからね
で お釈迦様にそれに報告しなくちゃいけないし
もうもう放っておいてもいいし
勝手にしろよと で またお釈迦様のところに連れて行くんですね
言ったら これはこの間の人でしょうと
なんだこの人はちゃんと言うことが真面目に聞くのかと
知識ちゃんと受ける人ですかと聞いたんです
どうせ初めからどうしようもないろくでもない人間で何かできますかね
言うことを聞いたりしますかねと
なんかすごくなんかちょっとそんな態度で聞くんです
言ったらサーリプッタ尊者がよく真面目に話を聞くんだよと
本当は私はものすごく厳しく
ずっとこの人を怒鳴ったり
いろんなことを言ったりしましたよ
でも一度でも一回ででも怒ったことはないんだと
何言われても この人は
言うとおりにはい わかりましたと
それはしっかりその通りにやるんだよと
いうことで 怒ったことは知らないと
それでだいたい弟子が入るということは
本当にすごい迷惑ですけどね
サーリプッタ尊者も別に弟子がたくさんいてほしいという気持ちはないです
お釈迦様が聞くのは もしね
弟子たちがね こんな性格だったら
あんたどれぐらいあったらどれぐらいの人の面倒見られますか？と
こんな性格だったらね
何人弟子になったっても構いませんと
性格はこんな性格であるならば
まあそういうことで お坊さんたちはものすごく当時ではね
もうとにかく逃げるというかね
まあ弟子入りになりたくなったら
なんとなく誰かにこれを責任の回して
自分では自分では弟子にしたくないって本当のところは
だから人間というのは
それが性格は悪いし 気持ち悪いし
もう付き合いたくはないんです
しかし 言うことを聞くならば
その臭いとは感じないんですね
ですから まあこんな風な人であるならば
いくらでも人が弟子になっても構いませんと
ということで まあ話は終わりますけど
まあちょっとのでも教えになった人には
そこはよくあの 恩返しするというじゃあとか物語とかいろいろあります
サーリプッタ尊者も昔もそういうふうにすごい恩を知っていた人っていうこともありましてね
まあここでこの師弟関係で良い弟子というのが
いわゆる良い弟子というよりは
この弟子は初めからもともといらん
仏教ではもう 問題は良い弟子ではなくて
成長する弟子なんですね
人が成長するならば助けてあげなくてはいけないだけの話ですよ
そういうわけで このたくさん弟子がいるんだから偉いお坊さんということでも
仏教ではないし 弟子が一人もいないいないんだからといってね
悪いということでもないし
まあだから弟子何人かではなくて
後輩というかね まあ人々が成長しなくちゃいけない
成長する見込みがあるならば
やっぱり成長している人々はそこはちゃんと成長してあげないとね
人間としての義務を果たしてないことになりますね
恩返してないんですね
人類には だから それで師弟関係成り立つんですね
それで師弟関係はどのように成り立つのかというと
ただそれだけのことで
言うことをちゃんとよく受け止めて
その通りにやるか あるいはなんでそんなことを言うのかとか
腹が立ったりを開始するならば
そこからはもう話は終わり
横終わりということになるんです
だから何としてでも育てるとか
それはかっこいい言葉だけで育ちません
だから基本的には自分の人格が自分で向上しなくちゃいけないんです
あんたはいい人だから
何としてでもこの人を育てなさいと言ったとしても
何をしたっても育ちませんよ
だからそれはあくまでもその個人がやらなく
自分がやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
あの有名なことわざにあるようにね
まあ水場まではね 馬を連れて行くのは一人でもできますよと
引っ張っちゃえば行くんだから
しかし 水を飲ませることは
300人が詰めててもできませんよと
やっぱり水を飲むことは
馬が自分勝手にやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから育ててもらうんじゃなくて
自分が育つんです 育つためにいろいろ助けてもらったりする
だから育ちますか？というポイントなんですね
この人は育ちませんというならば
もう手を焼く必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそのポイントだけ
そこ世間と違うところだから
よく覚えておきましょう
この別にたくさん弟子を作るという話は仏教ではなくて
育つ人を助けるんですね
ですから 育つ人を助けないのはとんでもない失礼なことなんです
育てるのに 育てるならば
もう例えどこでもお釈迦様はどこでもいらっしゃったんだから
もう何キロでも歩いていくんで
たった一人のために この場合も
もうどこに住んでたかはっきり書いてないんですけど
なんかちょこちょこと理解できたところで
なんか変な人がもうお寺に何か野良犬が来て住み込んだりするでしょ
野良猫とかね ちょっと餌もらったら
そういう感じで住み込んでいるところですけど
やっぱりこれは育てる育つ人であるとわかったら
ずっとそこまで行って
この大責任はサーリプッタ尊者に任せて
で 最高の環境を与えるんです
お釈迦様は誰かの比丘
あの比丘たちに 一人の比丘に頼んだらね
なんだらなんだらの森にある貧しい人がいるんですけど
あの比丘たちにそいつを出家させないといなさいと言ったら
それで話は終わるでしょうね
お釈迦様が言われたら誰も断れませんから
しかし 育つ人だからそんな手抜きはできません
育つ人だからもう最高の環境を与えてあげる
これでもかという感じで
だからもう世間 世間ではサーリプッタ尊者に弟子入りできればね
これ以上話にも言うことはないんだから
で そこ仏教はそういう風にあるんであって
誰でもいいんだからということじゃないんです
仏教にとってはそれ大きな問題なんです
だから性格変える世界だから変わらないんだと
頑固だったら意味がないでしょうに
だからそうなってくると
まあいわゆるエネルギーの浪費ですね
それですごい理性的な宗教だから無駄をやる必要ないんですね
無駄だったらすぐやめる
そういうわけで 人の性格ということを厳しく見るんです
頑固に生まれても その頑固さはなくして指導を受け入れるようにするのは
それでもその本人がそれをやらなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで  [咳]